- Give it up for Donnie, Joey,
Jordan, Jonathan, and Danny, y'all!
(audience cheers)
I know that most people
here probably know this,
most people in the planet,
but how did y'all first get together?
'Cause I actually don't know that story.
- Oh my gosh, okay.
We grew up in Boston, Massachusetts,
home of New Edition.
- [Kelly] Yes!
(audience cheers)
- Most of us were bused to school
literally two blocks away
from where they grew up.
And while they were famous, you know,
it was a really amazing
time to be a fan of theirs.
Their producer, Maurice Starr,
wanted to get another band together,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- after them, and
started to look for kids.
Now, the story is that there was
thousands of auditions, kind
of like an American Idol thing.
- Yeah.
- It wasn't that.
There was about seven people auditioned.
Thank God, because we probably
wouldn't have made it,
(participants and audience laugh)
if we have to go through
what you went through.
- It's a big difference.
- Yeah, it's a big difference.
But we were the guys.
I was the first member that met Maurice.
My brother Mark actually
was one of the first members with me,
but he couldn't sing.
(everyone laughs)
- He's doing poorly.
- I can't either,
but he was worse.
- He's doing poorly (laughs).
So, I was friends with
Danny, Jonathan and Jordan.
Over time I talked them into
coming and meeting Maurice,
and they decided to join.
Then we needed the special ingredient.
- [Joey] Ah, ha ha ha!
- [Kelly] The special sauce.
- [Donnie] And Joey had-
- [Joey] The little little guy.
- He built the reputation
for himself around the city
doing plays and stuff.
Maurice kept saying, we need that young
Donny Osmond/Michael Jackson type of guy
in the front of the band,
and we found Joey and the rest is history.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] It's so interesting
how it all plays out.